من العاصمه باريس حيث تشهد اشتباكات عنيفه
بين الشرطه والمحتجين على تمرير قانون
التقاعد الذي تم تمريره من قبل البرلمان
الفرنسي والذي يرفع سن التقاعد الى اربعه
وستين عام النقابات بدورها تفاعلت بشكل
كبير رفضا لهذا
التمرير لهذا القانون وبالتالي خرجت في
يعني احتجاجات مناهضه في عدد من الشوارع
في العاصمه باريس وليس فقط باريس انما عدد
من المدن الفرنسيه خرجت
للتظاهر ولمناهضه هذا القانون الذي يرفع
سن التقاعد الى 64 عام عدد ايضا من
النقابات
والقطاعات الفئويه دخلت فيها في هذا
الاضراب ومنها الملاحه الجويه وكذلك ايضا
عدد الجامعات قبل قليل علمنا ان هنالك
سبعه جامعات هي دخلت في حاله اضراب وايضا
قطاع الطاقه وعمال النظافه وغيرها ايضا من
القطاعات المهمه هي دخلت في حاله اضراب
بشكل كبير النقابات تقول بان يوم الخميس
القادم ستدخل في حاله اضراب شامل رفضا
لهذا
القرار الذي يعني
مررته الحكومه من قبل البرلمان الفرنسي
اذا لليله السادسه بدت هذه هي الصوره الان
من العاصمه باريس هذه التظاهرات التي
تحولت الى اشتباكات عنيفه بالامس قامت
الشرطه بحمله اعتقالات لعدد من المحتجين
في العاصمه باريس الذين خرجوا لرفض هذا
القرار اذن نستمع الى الاصوات التي تاتينا
الان الصوت الطبيعي من هذه الصور
[موسيقى]